si par exemple on laisse les centres
commerciaux ouverts avec une tonne de
personnes à l'intérieur et une salle de
sport avec 20 personnes
on la ferme c'est ça qui met le feu et
c'est ça qui vous met les gens
aujourd'hui ne respecte plus rien parce
que les règles sont incohérentes que
tout soit prêt à l'identité nationale
donc non je ne suis pas choqué parce que
tout est incohérent et que du coup bah
on ne respecte plus rien donc je
comprends les français qui ne
respecteraient attendu vainement attendu
rganisée salsa ou non mais ça me navre
magali avec tout l'amour que j'ai pour
toi ça me navre des 10 points comme ça
parce que dès ton discours est très
dangereux surtout par les temps qui
courent te dirai qu'on respecte rien
donc c'est l'anarchie et on fait ce
qu'on veut dans chéri écoute la question
est vous êtes choqués ou pas c'est pas
est ce que le gouvernement eut raison je
sais pas pour autant que je suis moi
pour le couvre-feu je suis désolé les
mêmes crétins qu'on va dans la rue
c'était les joggeurs qui voulait courir
tous les jours qu'on voit plus nulle
part plus personne n'a envie de faire de
sport les mêmes qui avaient envie de
dessiner au bord de la seine à l'époque
du consul mans parce qu'ils étaient tous
des picasso du dimanche également il
faut arrêter un moment donné il ya des
règles les respecte et le problème de
notre gouvernement sait qu'ils sont
tellement laxiste ou une petite
contraventions par si mes fautes et les
en taule fauté lors de la garde à vue
tous eux quand ils manifestent dans les
rues sont plaints de sauver leur tâche
ils sont à leur bureau en train de
travailler ils sont en train de dd les
vieux ils font rien que [ __ ] la merde
renversé des poubelles aller faire les
cons dans la rue faut arrêter ça il
serait important
[Applaudissements]
c'est que ce soit plus 21h le coureur
s'est dit hier une entreprise je vais
vous dire quand vous avez salariés qui
ont une heure et demie c'est la mort du
travail et mary attention à ce genre de
propos est sur les mêmes
tout le monde sait si je vous réponds la
storia ce soit en magasin sont pas les
mêmes pour tout le monde
soit tu confine toute la france jusqu'à
21h ça c'est une config à la moitié de
la france et pas les élites tu peux pas
empêcher les gens travaillaient mais si
je suis désolé on respecte pas je sens
même temps jenny n'aurait jamais donnée
mais lyon je ne sais pas choquer zhu